[Music]
the first several months is kind of a
blur I remember obsessing over like is
something wrong with my brain you know I
probably killed those guys in my head
you know a million times but at the same
time it was just beautiful now I for
sure see it as a gift I a great comfort
knowing that the universe is math
everything literally is math in the 90s
it was the booming times for futons you
could own a futon store and do really
really well
the economy was doing well and the
margins were good it was the Golden Age
of futons in the 90s for sure I was a
completely different person back then I
worked out six to seven days a week and
I had a spike tear on top and a mullet
and literally everything revolved around
partying and chasing girls and goofing
off I had been to this little karaoke
bar before that night I went there went
up singing a song had a coke and left as
I walked outside two guys there walking
behind one of them just smashed me right
in the back of the head for a moment I
didn't know where I was
I got where I was and everything was
spinning and I was getting kicked in the
face and punched I remember this feeling
of I am alone nobody's gonna help after
that attack I went to the hospital they
diagnosed me with like a concussion the
bleeding kidney and sent me home the
next morning everything was different
OCD came on instantly I remember washing
my hands for some reason and then drying
my hands them thinking wait a second
that towel was dirty washing my hands
again and getting a clean towel then
realizing wait a second I didn't clean
the knob so then cleaning that before I
knew it I had washed my hands like 20
times in less than half an hour I knew
it was silly but I still felt this
compulsion to do it I was really
depressed I didn't want to be out in
public remember
hammering like three layers of blankets
over every single window in my house so
that not a beam of light would come in I
would go out like to get groceries and I
would only leave at nighttime because
there was fewer people and I remember
sleeping almost for three days and
waking up and just trying to make myself
go back to sleep
[Music]
we have this knowledge the brain is
capable of calculating these amazing
things and some of those insights that
that are not normally insights because
we don't have conscious access to them
could be the kinds of things that we
gain conscious access to in certain
cases of brain injury there was an
article in 1967 by a psychologist who
described a young lad who had been shot
in the head and survived and after that
he developed some particular mechanical
and other spatial skills and it was
written up as an acquired savant
well I began to research the what we
know about the condition to that point I
was inundated with with inquiries and
new cases so I presently have about 70
cases of acquired salons in Rome from
around the world Jon Sarkin is a
chiropractor who had a stroke and has
become a an artist and has his own
gallery now Orlando Serrell was hit in
the head by a baseball at age 10 and
following that was able to do a calendar
calculating which is the ability to tell
you what day of the week a particular
date will fall on in the past or in the
future
Alonzo Clements had a severe fall and
then he went on to do his marvelous work
now as a sculptor when this new ability
emerges whatever it is it it's an
all-consuming interest and it takes over
the person's life so it becomes as much
of a force as a gift because they can't
turn it off it was a very dark bleak
time but at the same time there was this
Beauty to the universe and to the way
things moved that I had never seen
before
I remember looking at water going down
the drain and being absolutely instantly
fascinated with it it looked like these
little tangent lines that were rotating
and getting tinier as it as it went down
the smoothness of the water was gone and
then when I would see things on TV or on
the wall or anywhere in the world I
would notice the exact same shapes all
over the place it's literally everywhere
one day I left the house and I saw the
Sun and I realized that I hadn't seen
the Sun it had to have been like three
or four months
my brain was overstimulated I was
noticing everything that I hadn't
noticed before
[Music]
the clouds and water and light bouncing
off water raindrops hitting the puddle
and watching all the raindrops overlap
each other to create these new waves I
knew was math and I knew it was all
related to pie one day I drew just the
basic concept you know like I I sub
divided a circle into like eight pieces
and then like twelve pieces just to get
the idea across as I drew it became very
therapeutic
it's like the one time that all the
stuff that is going on in my head kind
of goes away you know I forget about
germs I forget about everything and
nothing exists but what I'm doing so it
was very different having both of these
feelings at the same time you know being
so depressed but at the same time being
so happy about that one aspect of life
but at the same time I was also you know
doubting myself too what if I'm that guy
who thinks I see everything as a portion
as pieces of pie and I'm the only one
that sees it and it's not real I got a
email from Jason Padgett he was
wondering am I losing my mind yeah you
know am I going crazy when he contacted
me I thought that maybe he would fit
into a group study on soon as to us soon
as he shows a special blending of the
senses or streams within one sentence to
hear a picture or to see a sound Jason
Padgett's synesthesia is unique so the
way that he sees the world is in terms
of your medical patterns but then he
also has those geometrical patterns in
response to mathematical formulas so he
became his own case study because we
thought his condition was very
interesting
[Music]
if my is a kind of brain scan that
meshes the amount of oxygen in the blood
in different areas of the brain they put
me in the machine they would have a
little screen in front of me even though
I'm in that little tube so we were in a
random order showing formulas that would
introduce his anesthetic images and then
dummy formulas that did not induce
synesthesia we saw very left-sided
activity on the top of the head which is
involved in mathematical activity and
some in the frontal areas of the brain
Jason isn't acquired on in the mugging
there was some brain damage and then
there was recruitment of intact cortical
tissue elsewhere rewiring to that and
then release of this mathematical a
dormant potential it was a relief I've
worried a lot over whether this was
something that would eventually be fatal
or could eventually cause you know
dementia and all sorts of other problems
that we now find are associated with
brain injuries
what really changed everything was going
back to school I still had OCD really
badly the first day coming into class I
had a suitcase when I had bleach wipes
and all the stuff and I cleaned off the
entire table and the chairs and my
teacher graphed an equation and I said
you mean all these equations you can
graph into a shape and she goes yes and
I go then we are talking about the same
thing just in two different ways
Jason is one of the most memorable
students I have ever had he was seeing
these things which exist in the world
but he didn't have the mathematical
vocabulary to communicate them to other
people clearly he could not stop drawing
these things because he was so desperate
to communicate it to somebody else
it gave me an outlet to talk to somebody
who knew what they were doing in
traditional math sense and it wasn't
just going back to school to learn stuff
by going back to school it made me come
back out into the world within just a
few days I was in the cafeteria drawing
and that was when I met my wife we
started going out which meant I was
coming out into the world regularly and
I was going to school it broke me out of
that depression that gave me something
bright to look forward to in life from
that point on everything just changed
for the better
dramatically the brain comes loaded with
all sorts of factory-installed
software to which most of us don't have
access a major question that that faces
us with acquired savant syndrome is how
can one tap that dormant potential
without having a head injury or some
kind of central nervous system incident
we know what school goes on when people
have a brain injury more or less but we
could use some kind of simulation maybe
but this what it is that sometimes gives
rise to savant skills so soon a seizure
there's also the possibility of using
transcranial magnetic stimulation which
is a big magnet that you put on the top
of the head so you
simulate a lesion in the brain to induce
special skills in people who don't have
those skills
just like religion gives a lot of people
solace math does that to me now I for
sure see it as a gift absolutely of all
these events hadn't happened you know I
wouldn't bet my wife wouldn't have my my
children now I feel very lucky
am I gonna discover some new wonderful
thing it is possible but what it looks
like the real benefit of this is going
to be is my ability to connect I feel I
will have a much larger impact by
getting more people to go into science
and math and or even just understand it
on a slightly higher level that will
change things in a much greater way than
just finding one new theorem
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]